today on our show whose nose knows the
nood nood nood that's right we're gonna
take our shirts off man it gets sexy as
we talk about today's packed episode
lots of news comic book news John who's
moving to his TV news all over your face
neck and chest on today's back and I'm
Batman
[Music]
welcome to fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith pardon me yeah we're just gonna
talk about news this week is all the
news that's fit to print and whatnot
lots of stuff to cover flap it on your
face like a salmon Oh or a big wet [ __ ]
or a salmon get out of salmon and move
into spiders yes hell of a nasty segue
see spider-man movie has a title mark
tom is spider-man : homecoming the word
colons not an interesting call it looks
so much like that looks so much like
this spider-man is amazing friends logo
yeah immediately I was like oh my god
spider-man is amazing friend I kind of
love that homecoming as a title yeah not
as filthy as they mean it I'm sure but
refers to the high school dance pretty
much like after a summer you're coming
back from to school your home of your
friends and your family so it feels like
since we know well mark has seen civil
war and we also know that the boy
playing spider-man Tom began Tom Allen
is a kid but they're playing this guy as
high school told Peter Parker straight
up so the so this when they say
homecoming it's probably yeah the
homecoming homecoming dance on comes out
for some reason that just made me really
excited like that's a great idea like
that's the one thing that I'd never
exploit so much in those spider-man
movies is him in high school
yeah like more that particularly him
being young I mean we saw him graduate
in the recent spider-man movie and you
know Tobey Maguire it was always like 35
a kid in high school you look like an
old man's been saying not old but it's
certainly nice why are you still in
school that's why Flash's always try to
beat a muppet yeah he's just like you
old man get out of here get out of
schools I'm trying to take our women who
finally we're gonna see a kid spider-man
in high school I know I like the idea of
a plot taking place in the high school
there I was trying to crush and grow him
up into a twenty-something send him to a
college yeah go get your job work at the
Daily Planet and be a boy
let the boy play pardon me I misspoke
Daily Bugle not Daily Planet yes bugle
yes the buek now interesting they've
never been able to reference the Daily
Bugle in the Marvel movies
spider-man is now in the Marvel movie do
they are they allowed to references
finally hell wouldn't you like that
would Sony and Marvel are playing and
they're basically they're teeing him up
I wonder if they can keep going and be
like we want to use the Daily Bugle and
daredevil TV show whoever - they could I
wonder where if Sony's like no come on
asking for a little much we said it's
okay second base no we're fixing
spider-man for you so like all right
take it stop it just it's not nothing
that bugs me but when you watch
daredevil Ben Urich wrote for the Daily
Bugle who's nice because it all takes
place in that world but because you know
[ __ ] yeah it's like the tony in
spider-man when they started they call
it something else in the show but it'd
be nice if they retcon this little thing
these are white [ __ ] what do they
call white man's problems the first
world problems if some [ __ ] where I'm
like it'd be really nice mark if they
just tied those two still together you
can work on like cancer didn't you see
spider-man with his eyes and [ __ ] like
don't we do enough and like yeah but
come on just if you could correct that
bugle thing then just just for me then
I'd be interested it's a little thing
this sounds like a great [ __ ] movie
then there's a little bit of additional
news mm-hmm
tell us about it there's villain talk
for this mu and the villain there rumor
rumored villain is the vulture yes so we
haven't seen him yet in the spider-man
movies we saw a costume where the wings
were like that when once upon a time
they were setting up the sinister six
yeah which just kind of went away we
can't not happening so this is the first
time we see the vulture now if this is
to be true to be trusted this piece of
information this comes from a hollow
reporter man from the heat vision
section along border Michael Keaton
Batman himself could be the vulture once
again the bird
man that's true he's vermin this is a
guy he'd be Walker between two worlds
and he would be a high order version of
that because he's [ __ ] our cinematic
Batman I know now becoming a Marvel
Veloster nominee and an Oscar nominee
yeah he's a [ __ ] actor
I just watched his last time he's hosted
SNL he was [ __ ] hysterical and you
forget because like that's his
background is very comedic yeah he's mr.
mom he's mr. mom he's night shift
remember that put mayonnaise you feed
the tuna mayonnaise oh this is brilliant
call starkest 222 tweeting is Jesse even
called Billy plays prostitution - tit -
shun to say no thanks I want and we
don't need that part is a good flick all
right
spider-man homecoming yes can't wait
crazy you have to sing spider-man in
Civil War I just want more of that right
all the time right away man for those
that don't remember marks bragging about
having seen Civil War
yes I'm sorry did I mention it so civil
let's move into other Marvel news this
on television
hmm iron fist yes
iron fist is coming together the story
of Danny Rand who wears the most
elaborate headscarf in Mobile universe
they've cast of course Finn Jones as
Danny ran slashed the iron fist
Jessica hen wick is playing Colleen wing
but they've just announced that David
went him do we have a picture of mr.
Wenham has been cast as Harold Meacham
for a mere an iron fist and Matt our
producer tells us that that's important
because Harold Meacham spoilers 1 2 3 is
the man responsible for the death of
Danny rands parents all these [ __ ]
lose parents they really do there's no
nuclear families and and is there any
hero that's just like not a great
upbringing my mom and dad are still
alive I see him every second
I mean we go for dinner they tell me not
to do this but I've got to be accustomed
adventure it's also like Disney and
Disney does not have nuclear families so
this most true yeah it's like were they
happy you're not so much anymore yeah
that's our hero heroes and villains are
born by broken families without parent
Lee this big news apparently man they
got their killer right there ahead of
Marvel television Jeph Loeb we know Jeff
what an excellent guy he is says David
brings both a vulnerability and a danger
to as many diverse roles the key quality
creates this key quality creates a
gravitas our series requires as Danny
unravels the secrets behind Rand
enterprises dangerous vulnerability is
the name of many fragrance you wanna you
want to get laid you wear some of Marc
Bernardin's dangerous vulnerability just
behind the ears
all right so that's interesting let's do
it like that it's it gets closer one
more Marvel show it's a show that's
happening clearly and it's good again
like that [ __ ] character is visually
arresting so this show is happening
after the Luke Cage show correct Kate
show is already shooting I think it
might be close to done yeah yeah that's
right and I think it's uh means that'll
be the second one around September 30th
so will there be a Jessica Jones before
that or the next one is power is a Luke
Luke Cage Luke Cage then there's cajones
I think it's Luke yeah I think it's Luke
Cage iron fist and then maybe daredevil
season dude okay that's that according
to Charlie Cox who I think was on a red
carpet said something to the effect of I
know we're supposed to start shooting
defenders by the end of the year Oh
where'd he say this I think it was on a
red carpet for something as these guys
get all tired yeah last week he was like
I think we're supposed to so shooting
defenders by the end of the year yeah
that'd be [ __ ] dope yeah so I think
we might get defenders before we get
season 2 season 3 season 1 a Punisher
they're doing it right over there Marvel
television killing it man Delancey Kelly
television killing it with [ __ ] DC
Marvel television killing it with the
Netflix show you're just I can't speak
for the others I don't do you watch
agents of shield I have done this before
we have
before I've I'm like five or six
episodes behind I'm trying to keep up
with Netflix thing I binge man like both
terrible seasons Jessica Jones like I'm
agent Carter I like quite a bit but
agents of shield is it coming back
somebody said no I'm agent Carter is not
looking like it's getting a season three
because they got her on some other show
she signed a pilot deal not that that's
always you know sort of bar for that but
the ratings were not good enough really
ultimately for them to come back
hmm all right let's talk about a TV show
that's also based on comic book and it's
segue that's coming our way
yes soon very soon may AMC's preacher
based on the amazing comic book there's
an image of your Cassidy that looks like
a cover of the book right there it looks
like like [ __ ] covers the name of the
guy that did the covers blend fabric
that looks like he's Glenn fabric cover
right there they screened the pilot at
WonderCon and were numb word is amazing
really yeah I mean Anton I know it was
in LA this year oh that's from home it
was like two weeks ago yeah yeah a
couple of people that I know we're in
the house and it was like guys it's it's
really solid oh my god
engineered this is a show this is a
comic I've loved forever and it should
have been like an HBO series years ago
hmm and AMC being the new HBO again it's
happening it's froggit and your boy Seth
can't wait he's he directed he's excited
producing I think he wrote the way I
live heaven right Albert you never know
the word but I did director power
together still the directors not mean
yeah and directors of like material
that's not necessarily funny too yeah
and there's some humor in it but like
creatures rough it's dark good for him
he's expanding and [ __ ] there's a
filmmaker Seth Rogen taking over the
world son portfolio bigger a little bit
he's diversifying son beginning thor
ragnarok ring
we got a new cast member and that is
Tessa Thompson yes from the Creek from
Creed we love creator i watch street
again on a [ __ ] plane dude it holds
up then I went back and just watched the
fight like somebody jumps into the ring
the [ __ ] the Liverpudlian guy
different champ he's great in that movie
too there's not only Creed he's just
like you're the future of this division
may respect yeah her shoes and she was
also an dear white people which is a
[ __ ] really good movie and I think
most she and something else are just
those two good just those two for now I
don't think she was in dope which is the
other thing I thought she might have
been in but so she has joined the cast
of Thor Ragnarok but in a Iraq disclosed
room in Arakan an undisclosed role I
think it is I don't know I think the the
rumor that I've heard floating around is
that Thor Ragnarok is either going to be
like a road movie between Bruce Banner
and and Thor or at ease up Planet Hulk
is the other thing that I heard I can't
be there well we know that Wolverine 3
the newsroom this week is set is gonna
be set in the future right which makes
it even more likely that we're gonna see
old man Logan yep I love this world
where they're picking up our storylines
and [ __ ] our favorite storylines
well-known storylines and doing a
cinematic turn on them like you know so
often like Tim Burton's Batman wasn't
based on any famous Batman story I'd
like some imagery from staff but and
just like to have been we don't even
have to reach that far back Batman vs
Superman while it pulls liberally from
The Dark Knight Returns it's also not
based on no a story that happened in
comics before right this is the smart
play this is like you watch Civil War
here's Civil War yes you know I remember
when they announced that that was that
the first one I mean well no I guess
Iron Man
manger Winter Soldier was like an Iron
Man theories before that and that was
based on what was that one
it's like the new extremis extremity
extra fat that Warren Ellis run so more
that home closer to that [ __ ] and we got
stuff that works we got stuff fed if
their readers like it and we'll go great
but the story's solid like we know it
works we need to tweak it and test
Justin whatever like sinking more
cinematic
yeah like Civil War was Connecticut I
think like a town of Connecticut got
destroyed by some weird superhero in the
book yeah in the book and some sokovia
accords because that's what happens my
inner universe that's a minor changed
but that's I don't think that's a smooth
move man you know basing it on [ __ ]
planet or leading toward Planet Hulk
making a movie right if you're trying to
make a [ __ ] solo Hulk movie which
they've done twice before and now they
got the Hulk in a good place with the
Avengers movies or everybody's we love
the hold we'd love to see if I could
solo movie that's the solo move you
[ __ ] yes for sure like you get to
reclaim all of the bad will that like
john carter from mars gave you like us
to do that the dusty apatheia ters and
combat in the arena and all that [ __ ]
and I've tested Thompson is like the the
lady scar was that who was that remember
like his love interest who dies on that
planet you think that's what they're
setting up for I mean I don't know if
it's the thing that comes not anymore
those are Josh no more zucchini jokes
that's that shouldn't be but if you do
this story where he goes where the
Illuminati or whatever send I can even
introduced Doctor Strange and you
introduce I mean
Reed Richards that can't have but if you
introduce the idea that the greatest
minds of them all the universe have
deemed the Hulk too big of a threat and
sent him off world it goes off world
falls in love she dies and he blames
everybody back on earth for that that is
a [ __ ] movie yeah that is a the whole
[ __ ] movie that is like a Godzilla
movie starring the Hulk that's what I
want please
Oh God Newt that was amazing
[ __ ] give me more of that please
let's talk Lucy Thor Wolverine 3 preach
Batman we talked about in previous
episode but Warner Brothers at CinemaCon
yes officially confirmed that Ben
Affleck thing that everybody knew like
why is this a story yeah look we we
think you know we're saying you know it
right I'll even [ __ ] say this part
like the other day low on our fat man
abandoned episode in Detroit I was like
Jeff John's been is working on the
script with with Ben Affleck buh-buh-buh
and a lot of sites took that around with
it like Kevin Smith confirms there's
gonna be a solo Batman movie and Geoff
Johns is co-writing I'm like that's in
the trades yeah everyone knows that
agent just said don't Ben turn it a
draft of his Batman movie yeah okay I
guess that's been then and so with this
news they were like but this is the
first time that Warner's has ever said
that Ben is officially directing and the
movie has official slot and blah blah
blah
I didn't realize there was no standalone
Batman movie in their six year plan it
wasn't a yeah another AC film look at
their place more fat thank you yes now
there's gonna be yes about and it's been
directing which is like that's what
everybody wants man of like of people
that saw of whether you liked it or
didn't like it
everyone was on board with his Batman
yeah stage is set for him so tell his if
he wants it is to just tee up and
[ __ ] so I'm telling you we had this
discussion on the [ __ ] Detroit show
he's a man that sets high priorities and
stuff like that likes to climb big Hills
don't count Batman Ben Affleck written
directed Batman out of Awards you know I
wonder if it's still gonna be old man
Batman I wonderfully that young him up
until an older story like that they
could do year one if they really wanted
to not with Ben
he's been Batman in those movies yeah
I'm a second ago I'm like this man isn't
genius oh my god damn it Marshall well
he would yeah I mean he would have to
not be Ben then I mean it still could be
Ben as the 20-year younger version no
just black in his hair again shave
and she rich guys [ __ ] bad-ass that
would be or how bold that would be where
he's like yeah I'm gonna tell your one
I'm using myself as a framing device mhm
and then I'm gonna have some other actor
play [ __ ] dead man find me whoever
they didn't get for han Solo get me
young bet regardless whatever it's gonna
be a [ __ ] a Batman movie directed by
the guy that directed Argo in a town
bring it and Gone Baby Gone like all
three of those movies points of a
[ __ ] amazing mind at work alright so
there that's happening grits that stole
Christmas yeah they do it again this
happening again and it is a cartoon this
guy made it from the same people that
did minions yes illumination elimination
they've got the voice for the Grinch yes
who who as we all remember very well
from the animated show the only special
Thurl Ravenscroft one yeah that was the
god the voice he did that thing of what
the Grinch he's the singing voice I
think the singing voice yeah oh because
I thought the voice was [ __ ] what's
his name the narrator worst Karloff yes
he did he was the narrator and that the
one who was like you're a mean one mr.
what's-his-name Thurl Ravenscroft also
the voice of Tony the Tiger
they're great yeah that's good to know
yeah Ravencroft also the name of their
it's the Arkham in spider-man's universe
oh that's where they put their bad guys
he's Ravencroft Wow
also Thurl Ravenscroft is the coolest
name of it that's [ __ ] Cyril that's a
guy that's like how did I never hear
that yeah and I also want to know the
negotiations to name your kid Thoreau
I'm thoroughly sick of your names oh
yeah
he looks like a thorough get it like a
curl but with a flint the grinch
mmm ladies gentlemen your Grinch your
2016 Grinch is going to be big that's
right the the eye of agamotto is gonna
be looking down on Whoville man because
dr. strange strange is gonna play is he
the narrator of the voice the Grinch I
think is the Grinch or both did Grinchy
Grinch no he's a narrator no he's not so
he's just the Grinch just because
someone else would be the narrator like
why are we giving one guy two bites of
the Apple we'll get him I'll get
somebody else yeah Oh Amos maybe you
don't need a narrator like The Lorax
movie didn't have a narrator that's true
great point I'm just thinking of the
[ __ ] yeah
old cartoon is he a med school dude like
that's why I like you know if they were
like direct Captain America too
I've been like oh it's gonna look just
like Captain America one and that would
have been a mistake
never hire me that's the point of this
unless you're the flash then army all
the time crazy I saw my yes
I can't wait dude it is wonderful dude
his first cut was 55 minutes my episode
of the flash that I directed we got it
down to the running times 42 minutes
it's it is my it may be my favorite
thing I've ever directed now that
doesn't mean like I'd suddenly don't
like the movies that directed I wrote
and directed those things but this just
as an act a directing exercise removing
scripts and [ __ ] like that and but how I
personally feel about material and
whatnot whether it generated from me I
think this is hands down the best
directing job I've ever done just
directing like I feel good and I've
gotten some nice praise from from
upstairs
it sounds like I'll be able to go back
unless they catch me with a [ __ ] you
know dead girl or a live boy I think I'm
gonna be able to go Superman
they called me over at marvel sniffing
around and maybe I don't go back but boy
oh boy it turns a lot I'm very very
happy fantastic and I've like I'm happy
to report I have one this is gonna sound
gross I've watched it no less than 50
times it really holds up I keep you know
what I'm Road testing this [ __ ]
because this is this is getting a judged
harsher than any [ __ ] things I've
ever done before dude cuz the other [ __ ]
that let me go for the leg it says crap
if you [ __ ] it up so bad but this is a
legit chance you come into my house yeah
so it's I'm happy to report you can hold
your heads up you don't have to watch it
with a clenched [ __ ] going like oh we
didn't [ __ ] him over again
he didn't fabulous he's very very happy
wonderful um okay I think that's all our
news that's all we got man so I got a
there's always [ __ ] marshy had happening
but that's all we're gonna leave you
with today finish the print yeah at the
Daily Bugle only my life would be so
perfect if they would just call the
Daily Bugle the Daily Bugle in the
daredevil TV show it's all I asked for
in this world that's it I don't ask for
a lot [ __ ] I don't want riches or a
[ __ ] hard body or a long dick or even
a dick all I asked for is just that the
Daily Bugle be called the Daily Bugle
you dare to the show and immortality and
the Daily Bugle yeah what a million
dollars live forever and call the Daily
Bugle the Daily Bugle the daredevil show
I wonder if that Sony cozy relationship
if that you know and is anybody thinking
about that or mind the only one I think
you might be the only one but I think we
should bring it to the to the counsel in
a world where you [ __ ] like will
create petitions to like [ __ ] caps
mission ever direct again or whatever
the [ __ ] put together a petition that
now that Sony and Disney are tight yeah
over spider-man share The Daily Bugle
bring it let's take it to the White
House there are people out there who are
just like you know we are our city was
just devastated by an earthquake or I've
lost a child all these things and I'm
like you know what needs to happen there
Tony
have a Daily Bugle Ola president I'm
gonna enjoy this part of my life because
the older one gets people start dying
things gets sad and [ __ ] I always want
to be able to look back at a time when I
was like my biggest concern is what I
really need to happen today you guys I
don't need that like transplant that I
was really hoping for I just need the
Daily Bugle to be at a deli but that's
why this [ __ ] matters do because I will
become so hung up on like why can't it
be called the Daily Bugle then I'll
forget about my own imminent demise I'll
forget that one day I'm gonna have to
give up this best of all possible worlds
that's my brains synapses fire their
last I'll be sitting there on the
[ __ ] right now my greatest thing I
ever did in my life is probably make
clerks at the end of my life I found out
that no good said I lobby so hard for
that [ __ ] daily view you guys they're
like he finally got what he wanted Hey
It's a Wonderful Life
be patient kids you'll get everything
you've ever wished for the angel will
get their wings Zuzu still has her
pedals patience you know what man I put
up a quote on Twitter I said from twin
beaks I said through the darkness of
Future past the magician longs to see
one chance out between two worlds fire
walk with me and I spell chance as in
take a chance mmm but it's chance one
chance like it [ __ ] blew my mind you'd
like this is why Twitter is useful I've
been saying that [ __ ] since I saw it on
Twitter that's about one of the most
metal things you could [ __ ] say is
through the dark put single single image
through the darkness of Future past the
magician longs to see one chance out
between two worlds fire walk with me now
I always thought it was one chance out
like you get one chance opportunity but
it's I was correct
- chance yes fire walk with me is in
quotes yes I never understood but I like
that makes absolute sense so one chance
out CH a and T yes meaning like fire
walk with me fire walk with me fire
water that's what it is it's an
incantation gaze upon my wanders in
despair 20 [ __ ] years for me to learn
but I learnt it all so it's not excuse
me kiss this guy it's excuse me kiss
this guy how about one I know all right
excellent although I do prefer to sing
excuse me while I kiss this guy singing
it's art I feel everything you need to
know for at least for now yeah thanks to
me and good old mark barnard meter No
thanks for hanging out with us in the
fat cave for fat man I'm Batman I'm Ken
Smith I'm mark Barnard and tune in for
the next episode same fat time same fat
channel smack yes calmly youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder